what's up everybody Welcome to candid
truth we're GNA talk about the truth and
we're gonna get candid with it I'm here
with my host Aubrey I call her host
we're both hosts there is no co-host
here how you feeling tonight good we
just wanted to say a very special thank
you to some people who have helped
support this ministry and make it
possible without you guys we couldn't
even be doing this we stepped out about
three months ago in faith away from a
steady paycheck we used to work at a
Ministry that gave us a a paycheck and
we felt the call to step out start our
own Ministry and it's
been an exciting scary ride to just
trust that God's going to provide every
month and he does and it's thanks to
people like you I want to thank Mary
Ellen and Troy and I got some other
people on here let me see we got
Wendy
um
Cassidy Brett
Jesse and others that are on some
different platforms so if you would like
to uh help fund this ministry and help
support you can do so by going to our
different digital ways right here we got
cash app at candid truth official we got
vinmo at Mikey Jenny that's my name we
got zel is execute brand gmail.com if
you know my testimony I used to have a
clothing line called execute and these
are just ways that you can support our
ministry we also have t-shirts on
Teespring there's a link in the
description probably not at this moment
I need to add that but you can go to
candid truth.org click on the shop and
you can see some cool shirts we got we
actually have some cool stickers right
now these
hologram um brainman logos and the truth
will set you free that's actually on a
shirt and hoodies and then we got the
brain man from the They Live parody logo
if you guys put in the
comments uh let's see what should they
put in the comments demons in the white
house if you put that in the comments
right now the first few people that put
that in the comments I'll I'll respond
to and ask for your email address when
you send the email address we'll send
you a free sticker um I really like this
one's one of my favorite ones but we're
going to get into this demons in the
White House Aubrey and I by accident or
by Divine appointment ended up in
Washington DC and so we took advantage
of the situation and we took a little
tour and we took pictures and videos of
everything we saw there and found out
that this country was not founded on
Christianity at all it's so obvious
there's actually nothing Christian about
it there I didn't see any even fake
representation of like in God we trust
or any of this stuff when we were in
Washington DC what happened was we went
on vacation to the Florida Keys and on
our way back we got um our flight in
North Carolina to to right before we
went to Tennessee got delayed 24 hours
we came back the next day it got delayed
delayed delayed finally
cancelled and they said the only way we
can get you back home is two days from
now and we have to fly you to Washington
DC so we're like okay we'll do what we
got to do fly to Washington DC we're
there for two days so I was like well
let's make the best of it let's tour
around and see what kind of stuff we can
expose by the way American Airlines
didn't pay for any of this stuff uh we
had to really go jump through some hoops
to just get a little bit of compensation
back for all the you know mishaps that
happened but while we were there we
toured around took videos took pictures
of all this stuff and when we got back
to the airport to to fly back home they
flew us to the very same Airport in
North
Carolina now answer me this if you're in
North Carolina and they say we can get
you back home in two days why would they
send us to Washington DC to send us
right back to the same airport two days
later when they should have just put us
in a hotel in North Carolina this is why
this was a Divine appointment we didn't
want to be there we would have never
paid for a trip to go to Washington DC
Aubrey felt the presence of Darkness the
whole time it was just it was it was an
odd feeling to be surrounded by all this
Pagan imagery that is right here where
our country is founded and uh you're
about to see you're about to have your
mind blown this is probably going to be
close to two hours just to give you the
heads up but we're going to leave no
stone unturned actually there are some
things that we didn't include in here
I'm just now remembering we didn't even
get to include a very important point
maybe we look at those pictures anyway
somehow but check this out so we're
going to look
at when we first got there and this is
just a video to kind of show that we
were there these aren't just we're not
searching Google for images we took all
these pictures ourself and a lot of this
stuff was like on the ceiling when you
zoom in like you can't even really see
this stuff with your naked eye I can't
read the writings that are on the
ceiling but you can zoom in with the
iPhone take a picture but here we are
candid truth coming at you with the
truth and look where we're
at our nation's capital uh in the shape
of a dome for a reason it's all about
fertility and if you see behind me
actually you can't see because of the
fog but actually there it is you can see
it in the midst a little bit that is the
Obelisk why do we have obelisks in
America it's based out of Egyptian which
before that Babylonian these are
fertility symbols that's the phallic and
then the pregnant belly of the dome
right
there Rome 2.0 somebody said that's
exactly right we're going to get all
into
that so what what you got any thoughts
to
say no I I can just Echo the
response that I had the whole time I was
there I did not want to be there I had a
bad attitude
I'm sorry I have no I have no bad
feelings against people who live in
Washington DC but it was the darkest
feeling I've had yeah and I quite
honestly did not like it the whole time
she didn't even want to go I was like
come on I think that if we go we'll find
some stuff that we can turn into a show
like I I was saying you know I just
really had to encourage her like let's
get out of the hotel and let's just walk
around and we did we spent the whole day
these things are far like long walks and
we had to walk everywhere and I'm glad
we did it now because this really
answered a lot of questions I mean
there's a lot of people so speaking of
questions look at this bus this bus says
Christian on the side of the bus and
it's telling you you can go to a website
to find out the Christian origins of our
country check this out this is the
question we want to answer right now was
our country founded by Christians
find out about the faith our Founders
yeah we'll see when you go inside and
look uh there's nothing really Christian
about what's
inside so I'm going to let you see some
of their website here this is their
website it says the path to truth is
clear learn the American story find
indisputable information know and
discern the truth I wasn't sure what
angle they were going with this but when
I started looking around it's says the
founding fathers on Jesus Christianity
in the Bible and it says for decades
accusations now this is what they're
saying that atheist will say this
country wasn't Christian accusations
against the founding fathers have
abounded one of the common criticisms is
that the founding fathers were a
collective group of atheists so this
site is saying we're going to prove to
you that the founding fathers were in
fact Christian and not atheists they're
trying to debunk the atheists who are
saying that this country was not founded
on religious freedom now here you see
Aubrey about to present uh a very
interesting symbol in this what building
was this this was the Library of
Congress library Congress what is that
for anybody that doesn't know I'm not
exactly sure it houses all of the books
um if I have the right understanding of
kind of what our government is founded
on history books but not only that when
you publish a book you get a I believe
an ISBN number oh yeah that goes back to
Library of Congress to kind of track the
books in the world and that's as far as
I got with my understanding of it right
there one thing that I I love art as an
artist I've always loved art I have big
huge books of Michelangelo and all these
guys and there's tons of amazing art in
there but it's full of pagan and satanic
symbols and you're going to find out so
check this
out um what we're seeing here as we zoom
in the uh the allseeing eye at top the
pyramid a lot of people say well this is
on the back of the dollar bill it says
noos order to chlorum which means the
new world order a new order of a secular
world and why do we have a a pyramid on
our dollar why do we just accept these
things like oh yeah that's that's the
logo that's on our dollar know this
stuff has Egyptian and pagan origins
that have no reason to be on our dollar
at all why America why do we have
anything Egyptian on our money this
comes from the Eye of Horus or the eye
of raw and you see it says um The W
wagget I guess that's the term meaning
whole one is a powerful symbol of
protection in ancient Egypt also known
as the eye of hor
and the allseeing eye so this isn't my
you know this isn't like my personal
opinion this is that's what that is the
allseeing eye on the money and so
they're saying that the Eye of Horus
this is where this comes from this is on
journey to Egypt website so if you want
to take a tour of Egypt this is the type
of information they're going to give you
there's no bias there's no Christian
conspiracy theory or anything
here just the facts
here we see the the compass and what is
that that's not the square that's
actually a triangle but we have the
compass again mhm the compass this is
all on the ceiling like I my neck was
hurting from just looking up so long
yeah and again what is this same thing
that is the square and what is that
thing called you
know you actually protractor no this
shovel thing oh the Trel it's a Mason's
Trel a Mason's Trel okay so we
have uh
compass
compass square and TR where do we see
these things in
masonry we see this is not a conspiracy
theory you go to freemason.org this
isn't a conspiracy website this is the
official website of the Freemasons and
they're proud to admit ad MIT that
George Washington the very first
president of this country was a proud
Freemason 33 degree Freemason and you
see him holding that TR Trel in his hand
and you see the the compass the square
all and the allseeing eye wait a minute
all these things are starting to make
sense right the things that we just saw
in the Library of Commerce library
Congress
MH interesting we noticed there was some
interesting like
statues all around this
place yeah they were all outside of the
windows they had like this bust you know
from the chest up showing certain heads
certain people looked like they were
from the Middle East with turbin on
there were certain ones that looked like
Knights of Malta if you will or some
kind of kingly noble men and then there
was another one that kind of looked like
a popper kind of like you would think of
Robin Hood yeah and um there were just
those three over and over again they
were different people but they had
different basically that soci economic
status
throughout
and as you look at that when you went
inside all of a sudden you would see
other Buss inside of the window right
and they would have
names and I do you have any pictures
like that I don't have any of the
pictures of the bus but here
on um library of congress.org or
whatever this is this is the official
website I think it's interesting that
the very first thing it says is
33 ethnological heads or ornament the
keystones of the first story Windows 33
uhhuh why why 33 I don't I don't I mean
it's just call me a conspiracy theorist
but we've already seen the allseeing eye
we've already seen the
the square en Compass we've already seen
the Trel we've already seen that the
first president was an open
Freemason so I don't think it's any
coincidence coincidence that there's
33 number 33 statues on this building
there is 33 degrees of Freemasonry when
you climb up the ladder of Freemasonry
you'll get to the 33rd 33rd degree which
is known to be like the highest degree
but I believe there's more outside of
what normal people
understand but you can even go and look
this stuff up it says what is a 33
degree Mason a 33 degree Mason is a
Master Mason who has been honored with
the highest degree in the Scottish right
and you can choose to read the rest of
it yourself but 33 is a very important
number in
freemasonary notice also this is this
comes from Masonic vibes.com
and notice what that number 33 is on
what is that a statue
of is the double-headed
Phoenix um which we will see more of and
where that actually originates from
somebody in the chat says Billy Graham
was a Freemason too that's that's right
I've actually seen it admitted on some
Freemason websites these people are
proud to tell you who was a Freemason
it's not a conspiracy theory a lot of
these people were proud to be Freemasons
they don't think there's anything
sinister about being a part of this
club so what's up with King
Neptune um Neptune is I'm just thinking
back to the presentation I did on
Aquaman Aquaman the whole movie is about
Neptune yeah and the underworld
basically that he's dealing with of the
cosmic sorry comic type of um mythology
basically and he has
the what is the thing called Trident the
Trident most all the time and which we
see you know in these pictures of Satan
holding Satan doesn't look like that but
pan did there were other um Greek and
Roman gods that held this trident too
right but as far as that goes that's
what comes to mind um we know that
that's Pagan of course we know that it's
really strange to see because that's
where the courtyard before you even get
to that's what I wanted to ask you about
like where was this why does King
Neptune uh have any significance to
where we were at in Washington DC well
right before you get up to the Library
of Congress it's not exactly right
before but you see this huge like you
were showing it's this entire beautiful
pool that's been made and people sitting
there's people sitting on fishes large
fishes the guy NE King Neptune's in the
middle and there's women who are
everyone's naked in the picture but
there are two women on either side and
fishes and they look like they're quite
honestly an e ecstasy almost like a
sexual
ecstasy
and this
is quite a few feet before you even you
go up the stairs next to it and you walk
through this Courtyard all the way up to
the Library of
Congress and that is their opening
that's their like opening scene to you
seeing what their country is about yeah
and
um what is to come I guess yeah so why
don't you read that for us by the way
this is from l.gov which means Library
of Congress this is not a conspiracy
theory this is straight from the horse's
mouth if you want to look up you know if
you're about to tour Washington DC and
you want to find out what you can see at
the Library of Congress you go to
loc.gov
so this is like the first page they're
talking about King NE King Neptune why
well it says at the front of the
building is the Neptune Fountain showing
King Neptune the Roman god of the sea
wait the what God the Roman the Roman
God okay and the brother of manura and
his court the Figures were sculpted by
Roland Hinton Perry Okay so first of all
I want to know why do we have Roman gods
outside of a country that supposedly
founded on Christianity already we
haven't even got this is not even the
tip of the iceberg of this documentary
this presentation right
now outside why isn't there a Ten
Commandments I I'm all about separation
of church and state but what I'm saying
is if this is a a country founded on
Christianity
and we have any Gods whatsoever why is
it not the Ten Commandments why is it
not Moses why is it not a cross or Jesus
or disciples or something no it's a
Roman god King Neptune all right so we
we saw this thing firsthand and this is
what it looked
like so you see right there this giant
sculpture that's bigger than I am and
all these other naked people riding
these different sea
creatures why why is this outside of our
US
capital so a lot of people think that
our country is founded on
Christianity why do we have
Hercules
Zeus
Apollo
Venus these are false gods these are not
Christian gods
so right there we just showed it they
literally have the names of false gods
Roman Greek pagan gods on the roof of
their ceiling on the ceiling why why are
we not seeing
Yahweh Ten Commandments Moses well the
only thing I could think as we went
through each part of the Library of
Congress was each of these things are
clue
yeah and each of them are Clues as to at
least who contributed to the building of
this country in their memorializing of
them right we build
sculptures and um allegiance to people
like there's sculpt you we got Mount
Rushmore and you have all these
presidents memorialized in stone you
have popes and all these things that are
Memorial statues are
about giving your allegiance to or
memorializing people in some way and yet
we have false
gods images this is a second commandment
right have no other gods before me or
maybe it's the third commandment make no
images before
me so it's uh keep God
first make no images yeah number two we
should not be having images in a
Christian of false gods there's just no
no way around
it so in Exodus 23:13 it says and in all
things that I have said unto you be
circumspect and make no mention of the
name of other gods neither let it be
heard out of thy mouth now this is not
saying like Hey we're reading this
presentation and we're we're condemned
for saying it it's saying when you're
saying these like we're we're exposed
losing Satan there's many times when
people of God said there's no power in
Baal you know they would say the names
of these Gods but when you speak these
God's
names you are inviting it's an
invitation for the enemy if you're
saying oh man I wish you know I wish I
could get help from Apollo or something
like you are telling the spirit world
you're giving them permission oh I'll
I'll appear as that God because Satan
appears as many different things he's a
shape shifter he's an angel of Light
he's a serpent in the garden he's an
alien whatever you want him to be he's
an ascended Master if you're a new Ager
you're a a dead loved one Satan doesn't
come out monstrous he comes out
as beings of light and intelligent and
these false gods all the people that
worship false gods in the Bible were
literally worshiping demons hands down
there's no there's no other way to say
it that's what they were doing the Bible
clearly says it in some
verses so let no mention of their names
and yet we just see them
engraved in the ceiling of our United
States
[Music]
capital so let's check this clip
out Coliseum where they killed
Christians in
Rome at the paron where there's a 40ft
goddess yeah this is not
Christianity so I have a question why
would we have Coliseum written on the
top of our building do you want to know
why it usually is in Freemasonry and in
the Illuminati why is that because those
are key moments to them that are
special events which Mark the dawning
usually of progress oh yeah and it's in
the trajectory they want it to go
but they'll tell you usually that it
marks a different event there's a pseudo
event in which they put out in the
history books
no and then there's actual event
usually but when we look at this there's
another thing they do which is confusing
to
people sometimes they don't change the
event at all they just have it in there
as though it was a somber event that
people are supposed to be like a poor
Christians
yeah exactly poor things but then
they're like yes the tarot cards said so
we followed it we followed exactly the
signs of the Stars wow and we did
exactly what Satan told us to do our
mission is progressing forward and we
are victorious we are winning wow and
we're going to memorialize that event in
brass or whatever it is engraved on the
ceiling so it doesn't have to be events
it can be just people that came on the
scene that had a
huge
um effect on society towards getting
everyone to move that direction as
well all right so let's check out the
next clip here um so this
is this is the map of Washington DC and
if you Google Earth the I put the White
House that's what that is down there you
can use a tool to draw and follow the
streets and you get an inverted
pentagram pointing right to the White
House actually if you follow this line
here you start to have the the actual
Circle that goes around the pentagram
these last two lines are the only lines
that are missing from an inverted
pentagram when you talk about blocks on
a street blocks are square these are
blocks they're blocks and my dad said he
remembered when he went to Washington DC
he's like man what in the world these
roads are so crazy because you'll be
driving this long road and then all of a
sudden you have to make this like I
don't even know what kind of degrees
this is 75 degree angle turn to go this
way this makes no sense this is a
architect's nightmare postman's
nightmare these angles on a street make
absolutely no sense unless you're a
Satanist and you want to make this huge
representation to the god that you serve
and in the city here not just that
usually you use a
pentagram upside down or up
right to cast spells yeah to put hexes
to use magic that's true and Satan's
power and Conjuring demons up for your
use exactly and if it's going straight
to the White House it's like let's point
this straight towards where we want it
to be used
from the leaders of this
Nation casting spells and using this
huge pentagram yes and we're going to
see I hope it's in there but it's not
just that star the pentagram that's
inverted
okay there is the owl oh yeah that's the
next slide actually okay good so this is
something that they they post these
signs up like this isn't even me like
using Google Earth and trying to draw
like oh it kind of looks like an L
they're showing you mm like it says this
you are here and you're on this part and
they highlight the owl in yellow the
White House right or what is that in the
middle uh that's a good question I can't
actually see that small okay but that's
what connects when I looked at it there
was the up inverted pentagram then there
was the owl I do see these crazy
diagonal streets that should not and
then they have a pyramid as well oh yeah
in the map you can point out so many at
least those symbols in the layout of the
map yeah that's already a cult it's
incredible
so an owl what what's so significant or
Sinister about an
owl it is let's see if I have that
correctly it was the symbol of
Ishtar for wisdom fortil
um and it really
just if you see that you usually can
tell that someone is trying to get
wisdom like think of um Bohemian Grove
right that's what I was thinking that's
Mo yes so you have well ishar is the
same as Bale and Bale is the same as all
these things they go so they're so
intertwined you look up like there's
this Roman God who actually became this
Greek god and like there's always these
weird connections like that evolution of
these Gods exactly and so when you see
that you can see that there is this
progression that's happening where you
put an owl in there and it's like this
is their meeting area yeah this is where
they are going to try to find they kind
of Truth when they said find truth again
we're going to see what kind of truth
they're talking about and it's pretty
amazing by the way these are very
humanistic people not just Pagan and
satanic but it's it's
all about man can do it on his own it's
all about man's knowledge not God not
not submitting to God and any kind of
way it's all about humanism but through
the rituals even that they do at um
Bohemian Grove you have this desire to
get closer to the one whatever the
Creator or the universe is it can be
anything but to open the third eye
basically to find truth through yourself
y that's really all I have to say so far
about it let's keep going because
there's so much to cover so let me full
screen this because this is a
clip so this is the Ora Boris right
there the serpent biting his own tail of
the or Boris I hope you can see it this
is a hand holding some kind of Staff or
dagger or something and this right here
is what I want you to pay attention to
this circle is a this is the snake's
head he's biting his own tail well who
cares what does that SYM around the arm
there too yeah wrapped around this guy's
arm who cares what is that the Ora Boris
is an ancient symbol it says the serpent
let me it says the serpent or AB Boris
surrounding this a circle with lettering
in Latin and Hebrew pen and watercolor
drawing so it's describing this uh
graphic back here and it says um
the black book a source book for spells
in in the Black Arts was the textbook of
the black school at Wittenberg Germany
purportedly where witches and Sorcerers
went to learn black
magic oh okay the next one or you no I
want to comment okay because
Germany all right if you don't already
know this please go watch Walter Vice
stuff the total umal onslaught he covers
some of this as well not in the fashion
we're covering it but you have the
connection to Germany that's huge not
just from Hitler and the black Sun cult
which is really what Nazism is yeah and
the Romans were truly started NASA for
all you NASA fans out there right Warner
Von bra all that look it up but you have
what's called a black pope and he's the
one pulling out all the the um puppet
strings in the world he controls the the
white Pope which is in the Vatican yeah
and he tells the movie stars what to do
he Jesuit theater yes he gives all the
predictive programming he tells even the
politicians what move to make next WoW
the black pope lives in Germany he is
always hidden out
there very interesting Germany is huge
in this and I'm not saying that I have
come from a German I Liv yeah my mom was
born in Germany so I'm not condemning
any Germans out there I'm just saying
that it has a dark past in these things
it's true
truly stemming from some of this well
it's just like we don't we're not
against Catholics there are many sincere
Catholics that are in that church but
the Catholic Church as a whole is a
corrupt system and if this is if there's
any Catholics watching this is your
first time hearing this there is so much
evidence on this where Roman C the Roman
Catholic Church came out of pagan Rome U
when Constantine supposedly had a
conversion and said he saw a Red Cross
in the sky and started painting it on
the shields of his soldiers and he went
from killing Christians but he couldn't
kill them because every time he'd kill
one 10 more would pop up so if you can't
beat him join them right so he he said
you know what you actually can go to
church but it has to be on the venerable
day of the Sun and if you C get caught
judaizing which meant keeping the the
Sabbath or the fourth Commandment you
will be killed all shops must be closed
on the venerable day of the Sun and you
must go to the church in this Temple has
all these Pagan Idols oh no they're not
they're not Pagan Idols Mars that's
actually Peter and Paul and all these
things and that's what you see in the
Catholic church today as well as a lot
of sun motifs Sun symbolism IHS we're
going to get into some of that but the
Catholic Church goes completely against
Christianity 101 Jesus said call no man
father but your father in Heaven yet
people call the Pope the Holy Father or
the priest Holy Father uh they say he
has the power to forgive sins that's
blasphemy according to the Bible there's
so many ways that the Catholic church is
not Christian but is also the first
Beast of Revelation according to Daniel
these visions of these beasts he was the
fourth Beast that popped up with iron
teeth and the first beast in Revelation
we're going to actually cover some of
that here did you have something you
wanted to say just to kind of make a
case that's closed on Soul Invictus
which is actually the conquerable son
that Constantine saw when he looked up
at the sky the God that he was following
is called Soul Invictus okay I've heard
of that Solon victus that's is a Sun God
yeah okay yeah so let's get back to this
Ora borus thing because the next slide
tells us of the oroborus emblematic
serpent of ancient Egypt Here We Go
Again a connection to Egypt uhhuh
America is connected to Babylon Egypt
and Rome and really when you look at the
prophetic timeline of History these are
all the the worst the the most ungodly
Godless kingdoms not Godless they had
their own Gods but Godless kingdoms of
History the true God yeah yeah when you
read the Bible it says don't be like the
Egyptians come out of Babylon all these
things and Rome the Romans killed Christ
so ancient Egypt and Greece oh yeah also
the Greeks um represented with its tail
and its mouth continually devouring
itself and being reborn from itself not
reborn in Christ but another counterfeit
reborn in itself from itself a gnostic
if you don't know what gnosticism is
it's the inversion of the Bible where
it's luciferianism where Satan was the
the the serpent in the garden that freed
Adam and Eve because he told them that
God didn't want them to have knowledge
and so we're going to see a lot more
more of
this where the serpent told Adam and Eve
God doesn't want you have knowledge if
you eat this fruit you'll be wise and be
as gods and we're going to see a lot of
this Gnostic stuff in the white house or
in the Library of Congress here a
gnostic and alchem alchemical symbol
that's Alchemy is a combination of
Science and sorcery black magic all the
way or Boris repres or expresses the
unity of all things things material and
spiritual which never disappear but
perpetually change form in an eternal
cycle of Destruction or Recreation
that's interesting when I think about
these false gods they never go away they
just change form they're reborn you know
it's always this Roman god turns into
this Greek god turns into this superhero
now which strikes me as the definition
we usually hear of insanity right oh
yeah which is to do the same thing over
and over and expecting different results
yeah Satan is insane yeah but the sad
part is is he's actually gaining ground
he's deceiving the whole world the Bible
says that the dragon will deceive the
entire world not a little bit not some
people not everybody but the Christians
the whole world and the more I look into
history and look into these occult
Origins I'm like wow man we have people
idolized superheroes that are based on
Greek and Roman gods MH people are going
to church on the venerable day of the
sun people are um you know thinking that
this a Christian Nation when there's
literally nothing Christian about it
people are keeping holidays that have
origins in Sun
worship and literally Satan is deceiving
the entire world it's it's really crazy
so let's move on to the next slide so
this is exactly what I'm talking about
gnosticism this was on the ceiling way
up there like you can barely see it with
your naked eye you can kind of tell what
it is but when you zoom in with the
camera what is in the picture
here
well did you want me to answer that sure
what's the picture here it's a tree with
a serpent that is a spiring down next to
the man he's pulling some fruit off of
that tree so it would appear that that
is the tree of Good and
Evil and it has this
word uh non solar so I looked it up
translated nons soless from the Latin to
English and it says not alone why is he
not alone I he looks like he's alone I
don't see anyone else around he's not
alone because he's right there in the
garden with Satan and he's taking from
the Tree of knowledge this is not a
conspiracy theory these people believe
in the knowledge that comes from this
tree and they don't even hide it it says
right here this is from that word that
the word that's underneath him let me
see if I can go back here notice this
word
El El El El okay now look now here it is
on
el.com and it says what does nons Solus
mean they're talking about it now look
at the logo there's something different
here that something has changed about
the modern logo why where has the
serpent gone this is now this is now a
grape vine instead of a serpent but this
picture was not found on the Internet
it's not photoshopped I took it myself
in the Library of Congress yes and then
it hit me quite honestly just a few
minutes before we were putting this
together that this was on I've written
tons of academic articles thesises
dissertations well not just myself but
I've helped other people and one of the
academic sources you are forced to use
is a
scientific peer-reviewed library of
archives that is called elier which is
this website that he has here in the
orange has the orange and the the
modified tree that is crazy so here we I
was looking up what's the story behind
the tree it says this is not my own
interpretation what's the story behind
the tree it says ever wondered what nons
Solus means blah blah blah blah I want
you to get down to this part where it
says although most Scholars agree that
the elm represents the tree of
knowledge look I'm not just saying this
Serpent and a tree is the tree of
knowledge like it clearly is but they
admited themselves the tree of knowledge
what's wrong with that what's wrong with
knowledge the tree of knowledge was the
Forbidden tree in the Garden of Eden
that God said eat of everything except
for this one tree and the serpent
deceived Eve into not trusting God into
distrusting God eating that fruit and
that's the very reason why we are in
such pain and misery and in this sinf
Fallen World I'll just add to that one
quick thing okay the way that they even
put nons soulless not alone Al means
almost in the back of their
understanding that when Christ or Jesus
created us we were left alone he he was
almost a um incompassion person yeah he
wasn't in in our Liv he didn't care and
then all of a sudden the snake came
along snake will be your companion
exactly yeah it's a gnostic take on that
it is and we saw that they had the
oroborus which was gnosticism we just
saw that back here look so we're we're
building a case here this Gnostic or
aborus that is a gnostic symbol now you
have the tree in the garden which is not
alone and they're telling you it's the
tree of knowledge now look at this inter
interesting
logo what do we have
here it's a dragon it's a serpent likee
dragon again around a tree now some
people actually believe from different
sources of reading that the serpent in
the garden wasn't really just a snake it
was this
beautiful dragon likee serpent that was
very wise and beautiful and colorful and
spoke in music and all these things
and here we have the dragon at the tree
and this word that's at the bottom that
says frat fratres de Sabio means the
wise Brothers Again associating The
Serpent and the tree with wisdom or
knowledge which
completely kind of tips its head to
fraternities Yes fratus means fraternity
yep it says it right there so when we
actually look at sororities and
fraternities and pledging and all this
stuff secret society exactly all you're
doing is entering into a secret society
yourself which is a stepping stone into
a higher more levels of usually a secret
society further on skull and bones is a
fraternity secret society that bush and
John carry and all those guys were in
but you get privileges of course for
being in that yeah
so then there was some portraits of
different things um one of them was
chemistry and I want you to notice again
chemistry you have this serpent for one
there's this woman that looks very
witchy a gypsy type woman and you see
this serpent with his mouth open blowing
a smoke into this um Beaker the
scientific Beaker here I think it's very
interesting
it's like she's again asking the snake
for knowledge about chemistry and
science yeah then there was this
interesting
picture erotica for anybody that doesn't
know what the word erotica means I just
put the definition here it says
literature or art intended to arouse
sexual
desires so it's eroticism yeah why do we
have I mean what what I've seen so far
and just what we've done so far I've
seen that this country is founded on
humanism Egypt Egypt and Babylon and
gnosticism and sex oh yeah I mean that's
what the phus is all about the Dome and
the phus right yeah it's all about
fertility
paganism and sexual desires I have yet
to see anything Christian I'm waiting to
see where's the Christian imagery here
so
manura who is
manura there was this this is the
picture we took both these pictures but
this is a picture we took of this giant
thing this is a rail of a stairwell this
thing is yes 20 feet tall but this was
different why do I say that because you
have tons of of leading balconies up to
these places in the ceiling which we
were reading right they kind of told a
story of who you know who helped in the
establishment of a government and had
specific skills and tools that were used
ideas all of a sudden leading up this
was a staircase specifically leading up
to the middle of the Library of Congress
as though this was one of the
leading God of gods that they are
venerating that's true or
celebrating they're worshiping it higher
than others as though they were not as
powerful so this thing that I'm holding
in my hand that's my hand this is is a I
don't know if it's a flag or a bag I
think it was a bag that was a handbag a
handbag it says manura on there I'm not
just saying hey this kind of looks like
manura this you know Caesar looking guy
by the way manura is a woman I didn't
realize that until I did the research
here but again these are close-ups of
this Mosaic it's beautiful I mean this
thing has Stones different color stone
it took a lot of money and a lot of time
to put this thing this m Masterpiece in
this building but again we have the owl
the Bohemian Grove um molok owl and you
found something interesting about the
things that are on this scroll what did
you think about this so just as
patterned after the ceiling they had
certain Al hoves within the ceiling one
of them was not just how academics
contributed to getting our our country
where it is today but then they had like
he like he showed these goddesses or
images of women or pan even or or
whatever Gods with their perspective
academic studies like chemistry or
Alchemy and ertica um they even had
theology in there which was really
interesting but what you'll find is that
they have another area where and I don't
know if we put it in there but they have
actual Islam Allah oh Buddha
confucious and they have like he's
saying then you have areas that
factually state
Rome um Pompei I forget what other ones
but you
have all so it was like academic studies
which have led people to where they were
different gods and Pagan goddesses that
have led us to where we are the kind of
like the tools and weapons that they're
us using against us to indoctrinate us
into what we become and where we're
going Arts Sciences you got you talking
about movies Games television magazines
Sciences you got Evolution you got uh
Greek mythology all these things that
are literally taught in these schools
that were forced to go to by law if you
don't go to school the government will
show up at your house and say your child
isn't in school we'll arrest you and
what are you taught in school humanism
secularism how to be a good slave uh
Greek
mythology and evolution mhm that there
is no God
now it was in the pictures although we
couldn't use every picture but they they
had one picture that you just looked at
with the Ora bis and it had Jay jaggard
was the last name on there this is one
of the contributors usually either
financially again or in knowledge or
something they were willing to give to
further the
cause um there was another one on there
that was pestil Loi pesi who and I
looked that up today pestil Loi was a
man from zorich Switzerland who actually
founded the way in which we do colleges
schools and teach children to start them
out
young you know as under the the cover of
No Child Left Behind y to indoctrinate
them into what we now know today as most
of the starting doctrines of gnosticism
wow and so he was also
Freemason his symbol was there in fact
he was a part of the Illuminati um as as
well and so you have it's amazing
because these openly admitted on yes all
you have is this this amazing symbol
that they have there like you said it
with the or Boris with the trees and all
this stuff and then a name a name plate
which states
so
almost without recognition just a name
that stands there wow and then if you
don't get curious about it you don't
look it up it's just kind of goes H
whatever in fact so many people seem so
happy to be there oh yeah just taking
pictures like oh it's like a palace oh
my goodness we were the only ones that
were like look at this oh my goodness
yeah we're
like um and so I did I started looking
up all the names I was seeing and yet
they even had Waldo Emerson so you even
see writers in which they have
purposefully chosen to lead the world at
that time into the era and the space the
head space they want you to be in wow
they have been chosen for their time
time and
place and God has us he's chosen us for
a time and a place amen and a purpose
and yet they have every step every
motion every decision every person put
in place just to carry out their mission
it's Satan in a chess game against God y
he's trying to
win but it was incredible because you
truly can trace that all back and how
this goes back to minurva yeah is they
had all of this on the ceiling
everywhere
and then when you got to manura up there
before you entered into the actual
Library Library of Congress the doors
you saw manura and this scroll and on
that scroll is listed all of those
things yeah see history so you have
agriculture
education mechanics
Commerce government
history as I'm right there can you read
that astronomy
geography statistics econ economics
painting sculpting architecture some of
this is covered up uh botany medicine so
yeah these are Army Navy I mean yeah
don't forget to read those ones um
treaties treaties treaties
Finance Art of War Navy Army finance and
the Art of War wow and that kind of sums
it all up these are the
tactics that Satan is using against us
and that our government is using exactly
against us to confuse us for one teach
us different things than we know from
our churches and from all this stuff
into their army into their Camp of kind
of mindless serving machines yeah and
when God knocks the blinders off your
eyes and you can see all this stuff
you'll realize all these wars and rumors
of wars and all this stuff look these
are the leaders of the world get
together at the United Nations they're
gathering together and planning all this
stuff they want to create a One World
System One World Government all that
stuff so people that are signing up for
these things you know I have respect for
people that want to fight for freedom
and all that stuff but just like being
involved in the wrong church or whatever
like we've been duped we've been trapped
we've been snared by the enemy deceived
by the God of this world which is Satan
the dragon and if I remember correctly
minurva is the goddess of war yes yes so
she is meant to wield all of these
powers and different practices and
disciplines in her very
attack on people that is how she does it
amen and the other thing let's see that
I was going to add
is that we just we need to be careful
what we put in our our minds and allow
in um there was an inscription which
he's going to point out now as well
underneath it
it says nil invita minurva
qu monumentum AR penus
exit and that means no invitation of
minurva thought a monument
in the air
perpetually when I looked at it deeper
um it did not just mean that it actually
meant nothing that is
done is not of mana's
will that was in the actual when you
actually find someone who knows the
language um they were able to break it
down like that so who is manura right I
mean the very first word Roman goddess
again all roads lead to Rome we keep
seeing like I I was told that this
country and maybe some of it is true but
I was told that this country was founded
on people who were escaping the
persecution of Rome escaping the papal
the papacy the Roman Empire and found
this country on religious freedom so
that we could worship God to our own
conscience and not be killed and all
that stuff but yet you go to our
nation's capital and this building is
full of Roman
gods gods of War which is incredible
because when you do talk about it that
way the first um fleeing from Europe to
not have religious persecution was
actually
that was their prototype of how to
indoctrinate the world it was force yeah
Force down your throat forced in every
way and then they went okay that didn't
work so now they're coming over to what
they call America's the new world yeah
the new world yeah and they went ahead
and said we're going to slowly cook
these people basically into our way in
of thinking in our Direction so it's the
same direction that they're wanting it's
the same motive and result that they're
trying to get but they're just trying to
do it just the sweetest way that they
can so you don't even get wise to it yep
Satan's had thousands of years to master
his deception and now it's like okay
Force doesn't work because uh people
will either fight against it or they'll
surrender their life to God they'll see
right through the the deception so now
I'm going to make a system that's all
about the illusion of Freedom oh you get
to choose your slave master yeah you're
going to you're going to work at the
grocery store or the restaurant or
you're going to work somewhere though
because this whole system has to keep
going the Industrial Revolution you you
cannot live off grid you can't if you if
you're buying a house you have to pay
property tax every year if you're buying
land property tax you can't just go in
the woods and set up a tent or build a
cabin and think you're going to live
there it's not somebody owns that it's a
system where you must be a good slave
and you're going to pick your slave
master oh you don't like the leadership
well why don't you vote in the next four
years maybe you'll get a chance to get
your vote and that's how they do it with
the pendulum swing there the agenda is
the same with it's two wings of the same
feather rightwing left wing that is both
why you have the double breasted Eagle I
believe because both come from the same
yes they are of the same flock or birds
of a feather and they're just two heads
that look different directions which is
the quity you see in most gods and
goddesses they have one face that looks
friendly and nice while the other is
like a demon yeah and because they're
showing it is demonology it's not just
mythology yeah when you truly get
underneath it it is demonology that
they're preaching yeah when you have a
king or Pope eventually people get so
angry that they cause an uprising and
overt that thing but when you feel like
no we might we might win this year they
say okay we we've ticked off the left
now we're going to now we're going to
give them their leader for four years oh
and we're going to keep doing our agenda
oh there's something you didn't like
okay we'll take that away you know it's
two steps forward one step back they'll
they'll they'll go about their
agenda until people get mad and say okay
well we'll pull that thing away while
they're in while they're instituting two
other you know rules that are taking
away your freedoms it's it's all a
patience game these people have
mastered The Art of War the chess game
uh because they're under the rule of
Satan and the black pope makes sure that
only his people are in office basically
yeah oh yeah his chess pieces are all in
it's only Democrat Republican you're
never going to get a third party or
anything right they speak the same
language they're usually of the same
Brotherhood not necessarily the same
fraternity you can have school and
crossbones with someone of the Bohemian
Grove or whatever but behind Freemasonry
and the Illuminati you might come from a
different secret society but you are of
the same same Brotherhood yep of the
world yeah you're so hid in the shadows
when that happens you have what is
called exactly that the hegelian
dialectic of where you're making people
think that they have the choice but like
I said the black pope is pulling the
strings and basically he's walking you
towards his agenda oh so they don't like
that option well both of my men are of
the New World Order Y and they will be
my advocates for this going forward no
matter what it takes oh man we just made
a lot of trump fans mad with that but
that's the thing you don't get to that
level you don't get to be a president
you don't get to be the richest dude in
the world unless you join the club yep
and it doesn't matter nothing's ever
changed I know people that say I vote
Republican because I'm anti-abortion
well guess what abortions always been
legal our entire lifetime it doesn't
matter if there's a republican in there
nothing changes it's the illusion of
freedom of choice in fact and I'm I'm
sorry but
one of their
other cards or weapons if you want to
put it of indoctrination and creating
this
hostility and polarization that was up
on that ceiling was politics itself wow
God did not create politics at all they
did yeah because when you do have
Division and you have people being
polarized One Direction or another to
fight each other you have exactly the
control of the masses to make those baby
steps toward words pulling the strings
to getting them to the the Finishing
Line where you want them to be yep it's
deception all the
way so manura is a Roman goddess again
all roads lead to Rome manura is a Roman
religion or in Roman religion the
goddess of handicrafts the professions
the Arts H the Arts and later War so
she's the goddess of war identified with
Greek Athena some scholars believe that
the cult was that of Athena introduced
at Rome so I was trying to see if there
was any uh Sun Worship in here doesn't
really look like it but there was a big
sun Motif behind the painting of her so
let's check out this interesting
Monument here we are Washington DC the
Obelisk the Towering Obelisk why do we
have an obelisk in
America do you know I do but we're going
to find
out wow we are going to find out what is
an obelisk well according to Egypt tours
again not a Christian website they're
saying that the Obelisk originated
during the early Dynasty period of
ancient Egypt again Egypt we got the
allseeing eye we got the Ora Boris we
got the
Obelisk serves as a Monumental reminder
of the civilization's Forgotten Glory
crafted from a single piece of
granite um it was the architectural
Innovation designed to commemorate
rulers and events and honor ancient gods
particularly who the sun god am moon or
ra it symbolizes the unity of existence
and the journey of the sun god raw and
was considered symbol of Victory
achievement and the pursuit of greatness
look why do we have an obelisk that is a
monument to the sun god raw the Obelisk
design a stone pillar tapering to a
pyramid top was intended to pierce the
sky aligning with the Egyptians
astronomical OBS observations of the
solar worship and solar worship so again
the sun god solar worship that's by the
way I don't think we would be really
caring about solstices and equinoxes
which is really what when the Sun hits
it in certain times of the year M it has
certain different shadows which it casts
like a Sund dial exactly that's sorry
that is why we have obelisks they are to
actually plan out the sun Wheel Of The
Year the WIC Sun wheel wow by the way
yeah which governs our
holidays and all the holidays are about
the solstices yes we wouldn't even care
about this like I
said at all if we were a Christian
Nation yeah so why is that so important
at the capital in the Vatican Courtyard
they have several of these across the
world did you know that the obelisks oh
yeah they've moved them from Egypt most
of the time directly from Egypt or
Babylonian centers of worship and have
them moved straight to areas of the
United States yeah and Rome yeah
um there was
something can't remember what I was
going to say about it but oh
these the pagan holidays the holidays
that we all know and most of us
celebrate Unown
aware they all point to Sun worship and
they've been veiled just like the
Catholic church has veiled Catholicism
and Christianity with Sund day instead
of Sabbath and these Pagan Idols are
really Apostles and all that you have uh
Christmas christ Mass which is not the
birth of Christ but is actually about
Sun worship that's what the evergreen
tree is all about the the tree that
never dies in winter is a promise that
the sun will return um Easter ishar oh
and it's not s o n by the way that the
sun will return Yes exactly it is s u n
yep perfect counterfeit
yeah so here we see more about um
serving as a
serving as a religious Monument H the
Obelisk was associated with the Manu
bird uhhuh um it says OB symbolizing
renewal in the psychical nature of Life
a precursor to the Greek Phoenix yep The
Rising Phoenix the Phoenix out of the
ashes that's all that's the same as the
or borus it's it's the resurrection but
not from Christ it's a humanistic form
or this sun it's the power of the Sun
and I'll just add right there that I've
seen quite a few Christians try to um go
ahead and substantiate why they are
getting tattoos of the Phoenix or double
breasted Eagle on them and they claim
that it is the very symbol of
Christ being resurrected basically
coming back to life and setting us free
I don't know how that came to be a
parallel yeah that is said to be true
but we found a picture even depicting
that of the tattoo no oh in the very
ceiling of the Library of Congress oh
yeah they had that D rested
Eagle trying to make it look like a
Christian symbol and the cross yeah
right there so it has long been thought
to be the same symbol or to be Christian
in that way but that's not true and
that's how they overlapped it to to make
you think that it was the dragon
deceiving the world mhm Obelisk were
admired and adopted by various cultures
worldwide with many being transported to
Rome during the Roman Empire again all
you know it's Egypt but it's also Rome
today obelis can be found in different
parts of the world standing as
Testaments to the ancient Egyptians
architectural genius and spiritual
beliefs oh wow that's why we have it ah
and so we have a question in the chat it
says so you say saying that the founding
fathers of America were
demonic I believe they were not
Christian they were definitely under the
influence of
demonic um influence I guess that's all
I can say may have very well been
deceived but that's what deception is
all about that's why many Catholics are
involved in that uh system because
they're
deceived so here is a we're going to get
to this Prophecy part because here is
Washington and here is Rome do you see
any similarity here Revelation where
exactly is that in Rome this is uh St
Peter Square okay so Vatican Rome right
here uhhuh notice the Dome the pregnant
belly on both these and the erect
phallic Obelisk
here okay this is I'm just noticing this
but is
the St Petersburg dome right there is
that also a blue flame on top of it uh
it looks like it could be I'm not sure
okay so that'll come up later that's
very telling very interesting soon as it
says image of the Beast here because
what is an image an image is a
mirror image or replica of something
else if Rome is in fact the first Beast
of Revelation which I believe 100% it is
just like the majority of Christians
long in ago in the past they recognize
that papal Rome was the first Beast of
Revelation and then a second beast comes
up and it makes an image to the first
Beast America made an image to Rome and
here it is in Revelation 13 11-15 it
says and I beheld another Beast coming
out of the Earth the first Beast came
out of the waters which represented many
peoples this second beast is coming out
of the dry Earth which represents a not
so populated area when the people came
here to America there were some natives
but that was
it this Beast or Nation had two horns
like a lamb lamb represents Christ a
Christian type Nation right but it
speaks as a dragon meaning its laws and
the the way that this nation speaks is a
dragon the is which is Satan and when it
says like that
means you know kind of like a
counterfeit a facade I have horns like a
lamb not not horn l or not lamb horns
but like a lamb yeah it wasn't actually
a lamb yeah and he meaning the second
beast America exercises all the power of
the first Beast Rome before him and
causeth the Earth and them which dwell
therein to worship the first Beast Beast
Rome so you have the second beast
America causing the whole world to
worship the first Beast because America
is the false prophet a prophet points
people to worship a certain person so
this second beast the false prophet
America is pointing the whole world to
worship Rome the first Beast whose
deadly wound was healed because Rome did
fall but then it had a resurrection
right obviously the pope is at the
United Nations all world leaders go to
visit the pope just look it up the
president every president goes to visit
the pope why whose deadly wound was
healed and he doeth great wonders so
that he maketh Fire come down from
heaven and the Earth in the sight of men
and deceive them that that dwell in the
Earth by the means of those Miracles
which he had power to do in the sight of
the Beast saying to them that dwell in
the earth that they should make an image
to the the Beast which had the wound by
a sword and did live this is the image
of the Beast that the first
Beast the second Beast made an image of
the first beast and he had power to give
life unto the image that's why we have a
living Nation
here that the image of the Beast should
both speak and cause that as many would
not worship the image of the Beast would
be killed should be killed so there's
going to be a
time when Force worship is going to
happen in America and it we already have
Blue laws in this country there's it's
on the books for every every state some
states actually enforce it Georgia used
to not be able to buy beer on
Sunday the Poland and Germany these
people already are under blue law where
you cannot buy or sell on Sunday the
venerable day of the Sun
there's coming a time where America is
going to enforce a system of worship by
law if you do not worship the way this
system says to you will be killed yeah
if you worship if you believe in the
system then you've taken the mark in
your head in your mind if you don't
believe it but you just do it because
well I want to preserve my life or save
my family's life you've taken the mark
in your hand by The Works of your hands
so so you can take the mark of the beast
either in your forehead or in your hand
but the Seal of God is only in our mind
it's our beliefs we're not you know
we're not judged according to our works
we're judged according to what we
believe but our beliefs will spill out
into our works you if you're a True
Believer you will have fruit you will
know them by their fruit not because I
say I'm a Christian or I have a Bible
you'll know them by the fruit so we have
to be sealed in these last days we have
to know
what is coming prophetically there's a
lot of people that think we're going to
be raptured out of here before the stuff
hits the fan and it's not true we're
going to be here for a mark of the beast
it's the whole mark of the beast
deception is for Christians the Lost
World's already lost if Christ raptured
the whole world you have nothing but a
world of lost people there's no need for
a mark of the beast the mark of the
beast is against Christians it says that
the Beast will have power to overcome to
take to have to overcome the Saints and
it's going to be those saints that are
um standing on thus sayeth the Lord and
we will not conform we will not we will
not uh conform to a forc system of
worship that goes against the
Commandments of God and this is this is
where things are going all roads lead to
Rome um so on the ceiling there was this
interesting picture which I will point
out just real quick this is one of the
first images that we actually see of a
full grown
angel yeah cuz there was a lot of baby
cherub angels too but in the middle of
this when they actually showcased an
image it was usually a goddess or a God
now all of a sudden you have like a
messenger of some
message yeah but what is the symbol you
have this sun Motif again everything is
about a sun and IHS a lot of people will
say isn't that a Christian you know
symbol I see that in Catholic churches I
even see it maybe some Methodist
churches or Lutheran Churches MH it's
not a Christian symbol why would it be
on the sun well there's a good answer
for that because the letters i is for
Isis H for Horus and S for set these are
na this is britanica encyclopedia
britanica and it
says the priest of Helio heliopolis
which Helio is the son followers of the
sun god develop the myth of Isis so Isis
is about Sun worship then you got Horus
again Horus in ancient Egypt religion a
God in the form of the Falcon whose
right eye was the son or the Morning
Star which is Lucifer so we have Sun
worship Sun worship and set he was equal
to the hawk god Horus which is the sun
god so IHS is not anything Christian but
it's the Pagan Trinity of Isis Horus set
and it's right here on the sun symbol
just like you would
expect and then this is the image that
AUB was talking about with these pan
Gods over here there's one on either
side that the other one's covered up yes
so overlaying the cross with Christ
supposedly on it over the double
breasted headed eagle it was supposed to
be considered something much
better
um so I just thought that was
interesting because I've heard of that
by many other Christians that they gave
that reasoning supposedly to
me um and I hope by now that you are
seeing how many
wreaths oh yeah are involved here or you
know half wreaths and so on because we
will see much more there a lot of
wreaths actually didn't get a chance to
that video but you'll see them
everywhere okay so this is literally the
first Christian symbol I saw in the
entire building I mean we had we had
this one which you know it's not
Christian there was a cross on there
this is the first Christian symbol I saw
and he's being dwarfed by these giant
double-headed Phoenix which look more
like dragons they do and I've seen these
in the Catholic Church why because
Catholicism Freemasonry all of it goes
hand in hand this is a Freemason
symbol um notice this says Scottish
right um MJ Scottish
right uh nmj I think it was like New
Jersey or something so it says the
origin of the symbol the double-headed
eagle symbol existed long before the
birth of Scottish wri theories have
circulated that the emblem must have
originated as far back as ancient
Mesopotamia was that a Christian Nation
no that was that's what Babylon became
yeah so again Babylon which became Rome
which became Greek when you know the the
Prophecies of the Statue of
Nebuchadnezzar Babylon was conquered by
Greece and that's why well the mes and
the Persians and then Greece but
basically Babylon became Rome Rome
became gree mhm and I believe now Rome
and all these
Pagan nations are America as well as
Rome Vatican uh says so basically I just
wanted to show you that this symbol has
been around for a long time and has
nothing to do with Christianity here it
says the double-headed Eagle on The City
Gate of in Alec
Hoy turkey I can't read that but also
I'm going to show you back to the
picture picture that we started off in
one of the first few slides from Masonic
vibe.com this is a Freemason symbol so
when you see this or the Sun or an
allseeing eye in the Catholic Church no
it's not the the eyeball of Yahweh
looking in no it's not I don't even know
what they claim to say that this
double-headed Phoenix represents and we
shouldn't have a symbol of the sun
everywhere all over the place in our
church there's many verses against Sun
Worship in the
Bible Sun motifs everywhere
this I thought this was a video there is
Sun symbolism everywhere around here
this is the Rising Sun on the pillars
between the
sidewalk uh to get to the capital so
Sun's there we got Sun logos here if you
don't know the swatka the swatka is an
an symbol of the Rising Sun and this
pattern all the way around the middle of
the ceiling Windows has SWAT SAS
everywhere not just there but also in
the tile and the floor M here I am
pointing out the symbol of the Sun the
swatsa you see a lot of other
interesting symbols there's a
sun here's some more SWAT
stias hidden everywhere in the patterns
of this building there's another or
Boris and so just to let you know from
Britannica the
encyclopedia underlined here it says the
swatka was the sign for the god Thor's
hammer this was Thor's hammer another
Greek
mythological God again in our nation's
capital and it says the Hindus and also
J Janus use the swasa to Mark the
opening pages of of their account books
um I'm just going to skip to where it
says right here a solar symbol the right
hand swatsa is considered a solar symbol
and imitates the rotation of its arms
the course taken daily by the sun I
think it's very interesting that they
say that the sun has a course and what
is the left-handed one I'm just
curious uh that's probably the Nazi
symbol or does it say oh the left-handed
symbol left-handed swatsa more often
stands for Knight the terrifying goddess
Khali and magical practices so it's a
cult Pagan wiah you could probably go
check but I'm sure that usually it's the
Sun as the main male God oh yeah and
then the moon right as the goddess the
moon goddess and I'm thinking that
they're venerating that it's one is the
Sun and then when it's flipped to the
left hand it is
the moon wow y the night and that's
there's verses all about not worshiping
the Sun and the Moon here we have more
here we have the sun Motif in the center
and all around the edges are the zodiac
symbols actually the uh tour guide lady
just told me that this flower is a
filler between each zodiac symbol so you
have cancer the
crab we have the um Gemini I can't
remember what these zodiac symbols are
this is
the you do see the zodiac symbols
though
Pisces so you know we have the sun in
the middle we have all these you know
this isn't just like sun and stars this
is
astrology
what's here's just a a better picture of
all the astrology around the Sun that's
the main room that you walk into before
getting to the side balconies that lead
to different areas and branches
of their respective um being me
memorialized certain areas that show
everything's being memorialized that is
a very good point it's like the whole
building was built built around the Sun
yeah and zodiac symbols so again branica
I'm only going to show you sources that
are secular sources I'm not going to
show you Alex Jones and anything Bible
related but branica it says the Zodiac
was divided into 12 AST astrological
signs each occupying one 12th or
30° of its great circle by the
Babylonians again how does everything
keep coming back to Babylon M about 500
BCE many of the Babylonian signs for
example the twins Gemini the crab cancer
the balance Libra among others are still
used today since most of the
constellations through which the eclip
ecliptic passes represent animals the
ancient Greeks called The Zone its Zone
zodiacos KY
Kos circle of animals or toodia the
little animals the Chinese zodiac system
similarly involves a cycle of animals
however okay so
basically the zodiac is astrology yeah
the Bible forbids condemns astrology
says stay far away from it and yet here
it is in our Christian nation's capital
there's nothing Christian about this
nation yeah the Bible talks about Sun
worship this does come from a Bible
Source Bible Gateway and it says Sun
worship Sun worship is ancient in the
practice of men evidences of sun worship
are seen in many cultures including
India Greece the Maya the Mayas the
Incas and of Central and a South America
of particular significance is the
practice as seen in both ancient
Babylonia and Egypt now it's starting to
make sense why we have so much Egyptian
and Babylonian symbols in the nation's
capital because it's all about this sun
Worship in Babylonia and Assyria special
sites such as
sapara actually I don't have to read all
this this is just to prove that sun
worship was forbidden you can see right
down here where it says in scripture the
practice was clearly forbidden worship
of the son and son images what do we
have in the nation Sun images everywhere
are both prescribed by God's law
prescribed prescribed that is
interesting not sure why that word is
used but God warns that he will destroy
the sun images and destroy the
worshippers the penalty for sun worship
was death by stoning if there were two
or three Witnesses look this was so
idolatrous so such an Abomination that
God said Sun worshippers must be stoned
to death
and we're building entire nation's
capital around sun worship Babylons
Egypt the Obelisk the sun motifs circles
and Sun diss to actually see these
motions of the Sun in the seasons to be
able to keep the holidays and cast the
Spells and worship the Sun and its
arrang pentagrams with equinoxes and
solstices yes they are putting
everything out there to practice the
occult y heavily
wow so we've seen one symbol of Jesus on
the cross so far that that's been
eclipsed by all the Pagan and and sat
satanic images now what's interesting
about this this door handle well so I
hope that you guys tuned in to one of my
other um episodes that I did mhm it
was what was that one called again
it was on the anaki and what the pine
cone represents it has a huge symbolism
here was that not in the holidays I
believe that it
was but might have been yeah it was in
the holidays it's been a little while
and I've been working on a lot of
research so forgive me for that but the
pine cone has huge significance in
which I guess it's weird why would you
put a pine cone on the end of a door no
um clearly not the very bottom of it but
on the top of the the
handle and there's this interesting part
it basically is
fertility it recognizes many other
things which I hope we have pictures of
because we'll be getting a little deeper
into it so basically this is a a staff
with a pine cone on top of it and this
goes back
to ancient times this was an AI overview
which you know say what you want to say
about I I googled this and it's looking
at every Source you see these links to
all these different sources and it's
saying pine cones have been used as
symbols in many ancient mythologies and
cultures representing a variety of
Concepts including Enlightenment and
transition that's that is the Serpent's
first lie eat this fruit and you will
have you'll be wise your eyes will be
open you'll be like God you're going to
transition you're going to evolve in
into godhood in Egyptian mythology the
pine cone symbolizes the moment between
life and death when the soul is guided
to the Underworld the third eye in
Hinduism and Buddhism it's fertility in
Rome it's immortality and eternal life
it's resurrection and regeneration look
our our we believe in eternal life as
well but it comes from Christ not pine
cones Awakening pine cones are
associated with Awakening why because
you're opening that third eye the
goddess of love Venus pine cones are
associated with the goddess of love
Venus did you read the fertility one
fertility in Rome the pine cone was a
pagan symbol of fertility associated
with the god Bale oh my and the goddess
Sabel so we're going to look at some of
these because this comes from Babylon
the Babylonian Gods of the
anunaki and we see that they have what
is this Stree um
this is
called the Babylonian tree the Mary Tree
by the way which we get Christmas the um
Merry Christmas from the Tree of Life
they call it which that's a cabalist
this is going from Babylon to cabala
which is Jewish mysticism yes and then
you have these are said to be the um
collaborating group of gods that made
the entire world human humankind
basically and that tree is set with pine
cones supposedly full of test tubes of
humankind ready to be um har not
harvested but conceived if you will yeah
and they're being handed to them by
usually a little more strange looking
this guy with the wings with wings yes
um because Angels they're Fallen Angels
they usually have a more um angular face
that looks a little bit reptilian
because I did believe that their gods
were Guided by a lot higher being that
were usually reptilian in nature and
would hand the pine cones to the rulers
at that time in
history to govern the whole world they
handed the pine cones and all the power
so someone asked how can this be that
our government is not Christian how can
it be demonic
well I'm not say the people are
reptilian but usually the more I I can
just attest to this usually the more
demonic that you are you start getting
this look yeah and they've talked about
this actually very recently where you
start having like this this really weird
I don't know do you want to explain what
that look is it is well I I went down
the rabbit hole in 2012 when God opened
my eyes about all this stuff about
Illuminati and things like that and I
started looking into reptilians and
things like that and I would see
politicians and celebrities and stuff
and you slowmo on these people and their
eyes their pupils literally turned to
slits I've seen a guy in another country
who's eating GL
glass and his eyes were slits I don't
believe in lizard people I don't believe
that anaki from another planet are
coming
here disguising themselves as humans I
believe when you open yourself up to the
Demonic world you messing around with
sorcery Sun worship Pagan idolatry all
these things you are inviting your
temple your body to be
inhabited inhabited possessed by demons
and correct you will start to see those
things those demeanors those features
will start to come out and I believe
that's the kind of stuff that we're
seeing and if you watch History Channel
they're all about pushing that we were
seated here by the Anunnaki the aliens
so just to reference this real quick not
to interrupt but this actually came from
my um my show on androgyny I covered the
entire origins of Anunnaki how it worked
what they were said to have done the
origins that they believed in the
Gnostic um origins of life and so on and
so you can go look at that there and
it'll be really helpful for you to
understand really that background yeah
that knowledge um that we're talking
about that I don't have to overview
again that video is getting a lot of
hits right now it's actually in our top
10 and um I've never seen anybody else
cover that topic no very in depth check
it out you'll have your mind blown this
whole
androgyny gender
bending uh fluid non-binary all this
stuff is nothing new we're not we're not
doing anything new this all originates
back to false god worship and again
Enlightenment you know it's all about
being a becoming a monk becoming a unic
you know when you become nonbinary
you're supposed to be the highest level
of Enlightenment as you can ever reach
and that's why they practice these
things so we see the pine cone clearly
there's an upclose picture of it um this
is a a search that was for what it say
the Greek pine cone staff Greek pine
cone staff or magic wand yep and so so
you see it over and over these are you
this one has the caducus the serpents on
either side this one you see this huge
staff this is a magic wand this
is uh Greek
sorcery that we see that's what this
pine cone is all about that's remember
the handle looked just like this right
it was a a staff with a pine cone on the
top a pine cone on the bottom and where
do we see this at well again Rome which
is all about Sun worship and came out of
Roman
paganism he still carries the staff
these are wax figures cuz these guys
have passed away but you see the pine
cone on the staff the pine cone on the
staff even Pope Francis has the pine
cone on the staff why why a pine cone
why does the Vatican have the world's
largest pine cone in the world the
entire world is right there at the
Vatican you can look this stuff up this
is official websites this is not AI this
is not Photoshop
it's not conspiracy theory this is just
facts we're just giving you the candid
truth here
mhm so there was a part in the library
when you go in the library you'll look
up on the ceiling and you'll see I think
it's 12 it says the 12 large figures
painted this was a sign right outside
the door telling you what you're going
to be seeing we did get video of it but
it's just we're trying to shorten as
much as we can I think it's interesting
that they picked this image because you
have the pharaoh
with angel wings and it says Egypt and
it said Egypt why Egypt well it looks
kind of like the gods of the Anunnaki
that were handing the pine cone to the
rulers of the world at the time exactly
and it says the 12 large figures which I
think is a counterfeit of 12 disciples
and just the number 12 in the Bible the
12 large figures painted Under the Dome
represent different countries or regions
of the world and a late 19 Century view
of their important contributions to
Western
civilization please tell me what
important
contributions did
Babylon gree Greece Egypt what important
contributions did they make to America
except our architecture our obelisks and
domes and Sun motifs and Zodiacs and
pine cones there's nothing important
about these things except that they are
blatant idolatry blatant Pagan worship
and blatant images that are put in place
of God oh this is very interesting check
this out so you got to see this is the
most occult place I've ever stepped foot
in look at this the true shikina is man
when the Bible talks about the shikina
glory it's the glory of God and they're
saying that man is the true Shak glory
and now look you got the Hat you got the
Freemason Logan right there with pan
playing the pan flute on the left and
the trumpet on the right this is
insane I this is crazy if you don't know
who pan is he is a Greek god of sexual
deviant he was the product of an orgy
there's nothing good about pan at all
it's where we get the story Peter Pan
they're both playing the pan pipes
they're you know he's going up to
Wendy's window come on Wendy come with
me and I'll take you to where the lost
boys are and you can never come back and
this Never Never Land um he's a sexual
deviant why do we have pan right above
this um this quote that says man is the
shikina the true shikina is man I don't
know but I do know that I was just going
to add that pan is not just of sex and
ories but rape usually y and and um
sexual deviance
beastiality as well as rage anger and
killing
yeah horrible why would you memorialize
these figures on the capital of a a
Christian Nation I don't
know it's not Christian that's why
that's why that's why we're presenting
this to you because we're unveiling the
deception of the enemy that this is a
Christian Nation that this was founded
on Christianity and it's
um this is what the shakina glory was
about because the word shakina glory is
not in the Bible but we see that it's a
transliteration of the Hebrew word
meaning the one who dwells or that which
dwells and was used to describe the
light on The Mercy Seat of the Ark of
the Covenant and the holy of holies the
shikina symbolizing the divine presence
shakan is not found in scripture but the
root word
shakan to dwell
the settling down to Tabernacle with to
have habitation and the related word
Mish mishon Tabernacle are both
frequently used and both are associated
with the presence of God and His glory
dwelling with man so when you see a a
quote that says the true shikina is man
that is the utmost form of blasphemy if
you wanted to say anything
as anti-christian as it gets is saying
that man is as high as God that was what
Lucifer said I will rise above the
heights of the clouds I will set my
throne in the in the heights of the
Stars here's some interesting quotes
some more very humanistic logic here and
it
says the first creature of God was the
light of
s the last was the light of
Reason yeah and it's interesting because
if you possibly go back maybe and look
through what we've presented you'll not
only realize wreaths everywhere but
this um lamp like a genie would have
that a genie comes out of I mean y
they're everywhere yeah and to say that
that and your senses is the first
creature that God
made um I don't know we're going to get
there I guess but their truth their
reasoning their knowledge that they want
you to have and that
they're um setting up is quite different
than you'd think yeah reason I mean this
is the Age of Reason quote unquote the
Age of Reason is when France was
stomping Bibles in the streets and they
were saying we're freeing ourselves from
God and all of this and that was what
was called The Age of Reason then over
here you see the web of life is of a
mingled yarn good and Ill together
gnosticism again good and bad Chaos and
Order Yin all creates this balance of
the
universe God a balance of Good and Evil
let me tell you and through balancing
that within yourself supposedly in your
decisions in your habits you supposedly
create God within you yep ridiculous and
so you know as Believers we're told that
there is supposed to be no darkness in
us you know light cannot mix with
Darkness but the yin-yang philosophy is
well as long as you have a balance of
Good and Evil everyone needs a little
bit of evil sometimes you got to lie
right sometimes you got to tell a white
lie to not hurt somebody's feelings or
whatever as long as there's a balance of
Good and
Evil so there's something on top of this
Dome out here and it is actually a
Golden Flame if you back it up you'll
see closer this is a Golden Flame
and we're going to see why is that so
interesting or important because these
Flames are everywhere all throughout
this
building you'll see these Flames these
cherub there's the word Moses I don't
know why he ended up there cuz nothing
else is Christian in any way but you
have Moses right up there with Newton
and this is the Library of Congress when
you get in there yeah that's exactly
what you see again all these statues of
men the Great Men of the world who have
contributed to building this agenda yep
demons in the White
House like constant just said um so the
flame what's up with the
flame oh wow this is a lot of history
again that I I will cover it but I
covered it already the Olympics episode
yes the dark Origins basically of I
think it was just the origins of the
Olympics but um this came from Roman a
Roman goddess named Vesta and in her
temples you would have uh first of all
she governed her hearths so basically
your fireplace and warmth of the of the
home temples conserve the city's sacred
flame symbolic life force of the entire
Roman State and as I researched this
again Rome you would have Vestal virgins
I believe it's about 16 of them that
were picked out from good breed
of of families of noblemen um the
prettiest um it's usually around the age
of 16 as well by the way and they would
go ahead and choose these women to be
brought into um the temples to serve the
priests and serve God they were said to
be the bridegroom of
Christ
and Rome in
Rome and they would dress in the way
that you see that here um in that
picture so I'll just read it in ancient
Rome the Vestal virgins or vestals um
were priestesses of Vesta virgin goddess
of Rome's sacred Hearth and its Flame
the vestals were unlike any other public
priesthood so why they're saying public
um because they could go to Gladiator um
events they could go get into the
spectator sports of the day or the
circuses and they could sit in the front
row like like the celebrities do today
or actors and
Superstars and they held a very
interesting position in Roman society
because their Chastity was a vow that
they had to take and it all depended on
this Chastity depended on the success
Victory fertility and
um I guess all good things of the state
and if you lost your
virginity um you were said to be
well for one you you totally had given
everything away you had ruined
everything for your life everything's
your fault and everything the the lack
of harvest the pestilence wow the
famines the armies coming to attack the
lack of spiritual dedication in the
temples everything just any any and
every thing was supposed to be your
fault and they would actually go through
all the 16 and like question them and
investigate which one had done such a
thing that they can go ahead and accuse
and that one that had done that if they
became pregnant and they were found to
be having that kind of relationship they
would actually be put in a hole
underground with just enough food to get
them through a week wow and they were
buried alive basically and that was
supposed to be a kind way of doing that
to them of ending their life because
they had sinned against God but they
tended this flame a very specific flame
in the
temples that we now know today usually
as the flame of
Lucifer and it wasn't to go out at all
and they had to tend it 247 in fact
going to these games I found pictures of
them actually carrying a lantern in
which they had the flame with them wow
and they had to guard it that's also why
we have the Torches in the Olympic flame
same thing and you have ambassadors you
have people who are caretakers of the
flame names were
uh ritual to these Gods exactly exactly
so this is where it comes from you guys
and today when we look at people that
dress that way you have women who are
said to be the bridegroom of Christ and
initiated into service of the church the
church yeah just to break all the
mystery of Rome we still have this today
yeah and how do we know this because you
can still see that I personally like to
point out that you can still see the
caves and the tunnels that lead from the
monasteries to the abies or convents
where the nuns live today and back in
ancient history were these Vestal
virgins that's what they were called
back then still nuns they conceived all
the time and they had to kill the babies
and they had to create a cemetery in
these tunnels they did that back then
and they're doing it now today vessel
virgins are nothing more than nuns in
our day and age and they are used by the
priest to carry out these rituals
Satanic rituals of fertility to the gods
every year wow it's crazy that it
literally says right here you know it's
they're virgins of Rome and for a
priesthood with the Roman Catholic
Church still has these virgin nuns same
thing and just so I can back that up
real quick you can go look this up there
are testimonies of nuns who made it out
of the order with their life many of
them don't and others are completely um
traumatized by the Satanic ritual abuse
they went through but they can testify
to all of it and so they clearly make it
known that this is a satanic order all
those things are happening to them
they're raped they're yeah molested all
the time by the priests the male
Monastery and order that also takes the
vow of
Chastity So speaking of the torch I mean
this this isn't in Washington but we do
have a Statue of Liberty which is a
symbol of our nation which came from
France the place that stomped Bibles in
the streets because of the Age of Reason
and this comes straight from Statue of
Liberty tour.com these are not
conspiracy websites the torch and Crown
you want to read that yes her torch was
added to represent progress giving the
statue a more peaceful appearance rather
than invoking violence
oh they say read our article but around
her head the crowns seven Rays from form
a Halo representing the Sun the seven
seas and the seven continents it also
evokes the official title of the Statue
liberty enlightening the
world so what is this picture here it
says recycled design oh my it's not the
Statue of Liberty which one would think
because it has all of the elements the
the uh the Halo I guess it has the flame
but this is
actually what we know of it's Helios the
god Helios which is the son God again
our nation the son of sons and the King
of Kings which is said to be the god of
gods wow and we still revolve around sun
Worship in mythology by the way yeah and
so here I mean literally if you look at
the Statue of Liberty she doesn't look
feminine at all actually when I was a
kid I asked my parents who is that guy
and they chuckled and said guy that's a
woman that's Lady Liberty and I was like
I thought it was a guy wearing a toga
just because he covered up his nakedness
from one picture to the other does not
make him a different gender right I mean
you literally see that he took off the
robe and this is Helios showing that he
is very much a man um but the face looks
very familiar looks very similar to this
painting which is said to be Satan
summoning his Legions right by the one
who made the painting yeah I mean th
this is just observation simple
observation if I asked you does this
face look like this face you'd probably
say yeah and i' be like oh well that's
Satan it's a painting of Satan there um
also Lady Liberty if you didn't know she
has some broken chains on her feet a lot
of people might say oh that's you know
representing Freedom her breaking from
the the chains of
slavery that's interesting because we
had slavery in America so it can't
represent that
I don't know maybe it depends on when we
got this statue I don't know the history
of that but these broken chains look
familiar as well because there is a
statue of Lucifer with these same
elements mhm it's called the Genius of
Evil by the guy down below and he also
has the chain on him he also has
ironically kind of like a Wolverine
looking looking foot with toenails that
are unkempt and an apple that's been bit
out of an a scepter that's broken the
top of the scepter the scepter is in his
hand if you look at it and a crown which
is missing some of its horns or whatever
you want to call it it's balls in there
and so how many do we have one two three
four five six seven a perfect match to
the Statue of Liberty
MH so Statue of Liberty tour.com
continues yes it says
while the Statue of Liberty is
undoubtedly Bart hold's most famous work
he was very well known for another
project a statue that was never actually
built years after he began the Statue of
Liberty Bart holdi was hired to design a
statue planned for the entrance to the
sus canal in Egypt interesting his
research led him to
ancient giant Egyptian statues and
eventually to the col Colossus of roads
this ancient bronze statue was over 100
ft tall considered one of the Seven
Wonders of the Ancient World the figure
was placed at the harbor entrance to the
Greek city of Roads showing the god of
the sun Helios carrying a light to guide
ships does this sound familiar someone
else from the Statue of Liberty tour is
saying this by the way y ultimately this
led BART holdi to design what became an
early mockup for the Statue of Liberty
inspired by the Colossus he created a
robed Middle Eastern woman a peasant
holding up a fiery torch he called it
Egypt carrying the light to to Asia so
showing the god of the sun Helios this
is the Statue of Liberty right here on
Statue of Liberty tour.com this is not
us putting together pieces that don't
fit we're being told from the horse's
mouth who this is so you see the
comparisons you see um Helios and Li
who's this libertas a goddess that was
also known um as another type of mockup
after Helios okay of the sun worship
again yeah so we know that sun worship
is literally just Satan worship and so
you see that here's some more beautiful
Aubrey here is going to point at an
interesting
symbol right here this stuff is just
everywhere o what is that strange symbol
what is that Pine con cone with two
serpents and the wings that's the
caducus that so the this is the caducus
logo you got the the serpents the wings
the pine cone which we already looked
into that and what is this symbol what
is this cross this double-headed cross
where the top rung is shorter than the
Bottom Rung wasn't the only place we'
seen it we' seen another one right here
with the pan satanic looking character
uh and this you know subliminal
Freemason Compass here and the the guy's
name by the way which was Trel Trel
who's that I do not know I didn't look
it up but this is his symbol and how he
contributed in some way well what is
this symbol it's the Leviathan cross and
this is from symbology Wiki not a
Christian website it says also known as
Brimstone just so you know cuz someone
asked in the comments inside the White
House no we are solely talking about the
Library of Congress still this is all
the Library of Congress yep I we didn't
even get to go in a white house there's
no telling what's in there so it says
the brimstone symbol is sometimes
referred to as Leviathan cross at the
bottom there is a li linous linous scale
lcap what that a linous gate the
infinity sign infity sign which is the
or Boris at the top there is a double
cross Cross of lorine in most Renditions
the horizontal bars are gr are graded
with the upper bar being shorter though
variations with the bars of equal length
are also seen the symbol has meanings in
alchemy the ult and religion so we've
been seeing already the occult we've
been seeing Alchemy they're blatantly
saying these things we're not saying
that they are mhm it goes on to say the
origin of the meaning being abundantly
available in Native form sulfur was
known in ancient times as is referred to
in the Torah or Genesis English
translations of the Christian Bible
commonly refer to burning sulfur as
Brimstone giving rise to the term fire
and brimstone sermons in which listeners
are reminded of the fate of Eternal
damnation that wait that await the
unbelieving and unrepentant it is from
this part of the Bible that hell is
implied to smell like sulfur likely due
to its association with volcanic
activity it goes on and it says in more
modern contexts particularly with
certain strands of Satanism the
Leviathan cross is sometimes referred to
as the satanic cross and is used
symbolically within those belief
systems this is literally in the Library
of Congress and both of these you see in
this video you see right there in the
ceiling the leviathan's cross right
there with
pan where we get the idea of what Satan
looks like a false idea of what Satan
looks
like and we have the caducus right
there why do we have the
caducus there's the
cusis the caducus
that's Hermes staff the protector of
liars thieves and
Merchants so the caducus is very
interesting because it is the staff of
Hermes who is the Greek god the guide of
the Dead Protectors of merchants
gamblers liars and thieves oh which I'm
I'm so sorry to say this if it's going
to hit you hard but mostly that's what
we were seeing on the ceiling was all of
these venerated celebrated Memorial
merchants of olden days that actually
helped establish this agenda of
Freemasonry Illuminati and the Occult
into our government today and gamblers
liars and thieves when you started
looking at the names that are on the
ceilings oh yeah that's what you found
yeah so that's what we have in the um
Library of Congress we got the
caducus um and Revelation 184 says I
heard another voice from Heaven saying
come out of Babylon Babylon 's
Fallen Generations ago why is revelation
telling us to come out of her come out
of Babylon my people so that you do not
partici participate in her sins and
suffer from any of her plagues look this
is just proving that prophecy is true
prophecy is being fulfilled right before
our very eyes yeah we are living in
Babylon the Vatican is Babylon number
one and we're the image of the Beast
Babylon number two it's going hand in
hand if you go to Hollywood they even
have a plaque that says the gates of
Babylon we as America as a nation are
speaking as a dragon we put up a front
that we're a Christian Nation but that's
the biggest deception in human history
at least when you go to China you know
they worship the dragon in America
you're so deceived that you think no
this is a Christian Nation that's the
that's the biggest deception because
when Satan comes on the scene as the
cosmic Christ he's going to come when
there's a time of great Calamity that
all the world is like we need salvation
we need a a savior because this world's
gotten out of control we live in a time
when people don't know what gender they
are there's lawlessness abounds there's
more broken families and homes and
marriages than ever
before everything Lawless is being
celebrated and that's when the time
comes when the pendulum swings back
because right now we are far left as far
left as you can get now the pendulum is
going to swing far right and it's going
to be like look this country needs to
get back to God this country fell apart
because we stopped having prayer in
school we stopped reading the Bible and
this country needs to get back to God
and that's the perfect timing for Satan
to come out as the cosmic Christ and
he's going to be doing lying signs and
wonders and many are going to be
deceived through these Miracles miracle
working signs Miracle working
demons in Revelation 18:23 it says in
the light of the candle shall shine no
more at all in thee and the voice of the
bridegroom and of the Bride shall be
heard no more at all in thee for thy
Merchants remember that symbol the the
protector of liars merchants and thieves
for thy Merchants were the Great Men of
the Earth for by thy sorceries were all
nations
deceived that symbol the caducus symbol
that is in that Library of Congress is a
symbol of Protectors of liars merchants
and thieves they believe in all this
symbology that if we put the pentagram
pointing right at the White House we'll
have protection from Evil and we can
cast spells if we put the caducus on the
ceiling then we'll be protected because
we are liars and thieves and Merchants
and it's sorcery that's what all this is
about that's why it said you know
Alchemy was in there that's why it had
um it didn't say science it said what
did it say it said science or something
chemistry chemistry and it showed the
woman with the serpent we saw the people
that were at the tree with the the
serpent they were saying that all this
is about knowledge it's about humanism
that man is the shakina glory all these
satanic humanistic
things phakia literally means the use of
medicine drugs or spells the use of
medicine drug drugs or spells
idolatry there was tons of idolatry
sorcery and Witchcraft all up in our
nation's capital and
I you really don't get to the head of
state you don't get to the Big Wigs
making all the money in this world yeah
you don't get anywhere in this world
usually without worshiping all of these
elements the symbols the idolatry
witchcraft part taking of phakia heavily
yeah when you do so you get privileged
by Satan for one but if you're part of
these secret societies they give you
extra privileges
monetarily um spiritually Satan yeah
politically um material
gain so everything and so you can see
that there in every single way and who
goes to who goes to this big cremation
ceremony of molok The Cremation of care
it's the presidents it's the judges it's
the politicians and the police and all
these people the the leaders of this
world the rulers of this world the Great
Men the merchants that have been
memorialized in our history books and on
the ceilings of our capital and the
buildings exactly I want to go back to
that look the merchants were the Great
Men of the Earth for by thy sorceries
were all the nations deceived how many
of us were deceived by these Merchants
that are casting spells over all of us
who make us feel like we're in a
Christian Nation who make us feel like
we can trust the science textbooks that
we came from nothing that we uh that we
we probably need to be on a drug my kid
he's a little he's a little hyperactive
just a little Aderall or has anxiety
over puberty which is normal for
everyone yeah if somebody's grieving
because somebody in their family died
it's like you know what you probably
need some ant depressants your your
child is only five but ADHD yeah no
they're an artist put them in a school
where they can express themselves where
they can actually do what they're
supposed to do instead of these
indoctrination
camps so if you would like to support
this ministry you can do so by by going
to cash app venmo zel if you go to
candid truth.org there's a button there
for donate you can actually become a
monthly donor on PayPal we need that
kind of support Aubrey and I stepped
away from a full-time check to trusting
in God doing what God has called us to
do with this ministry it takes a lot of
research to do this stuff I I feel bad
that we didn't get a video out sooner um
we were visiting her family in Colorado
and that's when we did the video before
this one where she was showing all her
handwritten research on this giant
poster board this is the type of hours
and days of research these these
presentations don't just put themselves
together we're not just scrolling
through Google and typing stuff and
saying look at this website look at this
website like we're trying to put this
stuff together in a
cohesive coherent timeline where you can
see the the evidence in order this is
the sun this is the obelis this is all
pointing back to Babylon which the Bible
says prophecy says that we're we need to
come out of Babylon that we're in the
days of
and Israel spiritual Israel we need to
be God's people we take time to make
sure that it is from credible sources
yes it is not just from Wiki or
Wikipedia or whatever those are our last
resources usually and when we try to
find credible sources we want it from
the horse's mouth either the cult the
government itself whatever the Statue of
Liberty um website yeah whatever it is
so it takes time for you not to just
most people don't even take the time to
do the research for one and then they
don't even make sure to get several
resources that all agree with them y so
that you double check that you're not
just making associations that aren't
there and it's hard to find you know a
lot of these people don't openly say
like yep we're pagans we're satanists I
mean you have to really dig on these
websites to find it thankfully Library
of Congress was saying openly yep Zeus
is out here or Neptune is out here and
so we hope you guys were blessed by this
uh if you were thinking of somebody
while you're watching this that really
needs to see this share it with them
please give this video a thumbs up it
really helps to get this video in the
algorithm we are um praying that this
channel has been a blessing to you we're
trying to get out content as much as we
can we do a lot of traveling speaking
engagements if you want us to come to
your church um you can book us on candid
truth.org we're somewhere away from home
almost every other weekend speaking
engagements or or visiting even taking
video at in Washington DC you know we
didn't just show you pictures from
Google we were there and we thank God
that we ended up there the way it
happened we believe it was a really a
Divine appointment and so pray for us
share this ministry give us a thumbs up
subscribe if you're new we're going to
have a lot more videos like this about a
lot of like pagan origins of things
we're going to be doing a video on
alcohol next
what does the Bible say about it what
does science say about it should a
Christian drink alcohol seems almost
absurd to even ask the question but in
these days a lot of people have been
deceived about a lot of things that we
do culturally we partake in pagan
holidays and you know intoxicating
drinks and all these things so we just
want to say thank you remember write in
the comment section some of you guys
have been writing it in the chat write
in the comment section demons in the
White House for one of these free uh
hologram heads or the truth will set you
free or they live parody guy all this is
the brain man logo because remember it's
cool to use your brain we'll see you
next time on candid truth we love you
God bless you guys and keep us in your
prayers good night everybody